[Musique]
mes petits amis
ce soir nous venons vous dire au revoir
car nous partons en voyage
oui nous portons
mais vous savez que nous reviendrons
très vite vous voir aussi je vous
demande d'être très sage et de faire
comme nicolas et pimprenelle beaucoup de
promesses à nounours jeu fun petites
listes patron vous allez voir bon le
cheval et aux propos beaucoup
n'oublie pas que nous partons ce soir
petit marchand de sable énonce on veut
que tu reviennes vie que vous n'allez
pas trop loin quand tu nous rapporte
quelque chose de beau cadeau et beaucoup
d'histoires bonsoir déchets regarde sur
la table on t'a préparé quelque chose
pour votre voyage
tout ça avec conçu rejoint tu coûtes
bolt sous
oh
[Musique]
merci les enfants merci là asseyons nous
ne partons que quelques jets et nous
reviendront vite vous retrouver mais
avant de partir je voudrais que vous me
promettez pied
peut être bien ça à faire pour me faire
plaisir et pour faire plaisir aux
marchands de sable d'autres amis
bien sait pas mais nourris entre amis
vous me promettez pied aussi de vous
coucher très vite chaque soir
de vous coucher très vite chaque soir
pendant notre absence
mais c'est promis nounours oui mais vous
viendrez le juré sur la tête en patron
sur la tête de mon pote on viole
d'accord alors allons vous tout au
maintenant on y va mise en annonces
afin de nous revoir à bientôt autre
tient tous les petits du maintenons le
marchand de sable va vous chanter sa
chanson à 20 images hansen bon voyage
[Musique]
je suis le marchand de sable
la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sûrement nuage
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage dans le ciel par
dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un type
eau en chanter et du haut de mon nuage
je serais même on sable doré bonsoir les
enfants du monde
à demain
bonne nuit moi je continue ma ronde
bonne nuit à tous les petits mots ne
nuit à tous les petits
[Musique]
bonne nuit à tous le petit
allons en route nounours au revoir tous
nos amis
à bientôt au bio tout
[Musique]
oh